So we're going to have one more quiz about variables. Variables are
a really important concept. We're going to use them all the time in
the programs that we write. So this quiz is going to test if
you can define a variable.yourself, and use that to do a computation.
So your goal for this quiz is to write Python code
that defines the variable age, gives it the value of your age
in years, and then prints out the number of days you've been
alive. You don't have to use your real age. If you don't
want to include your real age, you can make
up whatever age you are or you can use your
age in spirit. The important thing is that you can
define that in a variable and then do the computation.